and this is probably good human being
advice not just an entrepreneur and
startup an investor in vice the true
story of wine Larry TV was the day that
I thought I was going to start it I
thought I was going to do something
similar to QVC and I I don't know if you
have a QVC or Shopping Network in Europe
but QVC in America it's a show and they
sell stuff through the TV I thought I
was going to do the QVC of wine the
first episode of that show when that
camera went on and that light went on I
realized that this was going to be on
the internet forever
and that I didn't want to just peddle
wine I decided I wanted to be a value to
people in learning about wine because I
was scared that if I was peddling
something I didn't believe in that
somebody would come up to me at a party
and say do you like this and I'd say no
I hate it they're like well you [ __ ]
said it was awesome online liberty
you're a scam artist I'm like [ __ ] no so
I was very focused on leveling up and I
really believe the one great piece of
advice if you want to take anything from
this talk as we have to start realizing
that giving and doing things in business
without expectation of return from the
other individual is probably the
greatest leverage that you could ever
deploy in your business life though it
is extremely rare in today's business
environment and it has absolutely been
the bedrock of what has allowed me to
win all my engagement all my selfies
right over there in signing books all
the content I have nothing to sell I
have a book that I [ __ ] sell once
every three years for thirteen dollars
this is not about monetizing an audience
it's about building leverage to build
brand versus sales
you